[Applause]
[Music]
today's five because it's all think they
have got what it takes it eats brought
their favorite item from their kitchens
at home to help them today
and chef Gordon Ramsay will be giving
them his tips overseeing Quality Control
is a fabulous chef whose love of food
knows no bounds please welcome Edward
Lee I want to know what you have in
store for these fine five contestants or
today alright so today we are gonna be
putting your knowledge of a pantry
staple to the test now the three cooks
who do the best get to cook for me with
an incredible pantry of global
ingredients so let's reveal what's in
store for round one contestants please
lift your potions
it's beans lentils and grains okay
everyone's looking a little confused
here but before Edward reveals the
details of today's challenge here's chef
Gordon Ramsay on how to get the best for
your key ingredients right today you get
to work with these incredible beans and
lentils now here's the most exciting
thing about these they can actually stay
on your shelf for months and not lose
any of their nutritional value they're
packed with nutrients and they're low in
fat and sodium what would I do with
these
I master the techniques of lentils and
beans in India so they make the most
amazing vegetarian curries good luck
guys thanks Gordon cooks in front of you
are ten different beans lentils and
grains and 15 flags you must identify
the contents of each jar and match them
to the correct flag the three cooks who
get the most answers correct will go
through to round two good luck okay our
cooks know what they have to do but do
they know their beans from their lentils
from their greens we're about to find
out let the battle begin
alright let's see how they're doing
hey there amber do you know your lentils
for your beans and grains I put some of
these before okay are you finding that
you think sell to you I'm also hungry
have a meal and win a game if you get
through this challenge okay free meal no
worries
just go what's going on you're a travel
agent yeah so you [ __ ] well beans and
greens are global you have you traveled
to every single country that I wouldn't
be able to tell you that I don't think
but I've tried a few of them in mine in
my life hello there Chris alright now
you this homemade sauce from home
triggers it sit right here
yes alright so are you confident enough
in this or any challenge that you'll be
able to use this in the next round
honestly I'm a little nervous if the
beans don't come in a burrito I'm not
really sure what it is Oh a little bit
of a problem for you you've got them all
in there already yeah I think you're the
first one to finish doesn't mean I'm
right
where you think it'd be the first loser
the second guess yourself yeah I'm I'm
kind of lost on to yeah we'll see how
well do you think you're doing here um
you know salsa what would you say is the
most challenging part of this task its
deciphering between some of the things
that I've never seen before
all right well I'm gonna wish you good
luck thank you so much
which of today's ingredients are
featured most heavily in your
restaurants you know we use a lot of
beans but lentils are always on the menu
they're beautiful they're lovely to work
with and they're so versatile how are
you guys doing Jessica struggling a
little she's tasting them but I don't
think she really even knows what she's
tasting Brian seems pretty confident
about it but he doesn't have them all
right I know that she's doing okay but
you know a little unsure of himself
gotta go back and get those flags in the
right place and we have Jan of course it
looks like she's getting pretty good I
don't know maybe now
[Music]
[Applause]
just played a challenge but only three
can go through to the final round now it
is time to find out from Edward how they
should have done it so we have green
lentils split peas chickpeas fava beans
mmm cannellini beans
buckwheat bulgur wheat couscous
maybe beans and poia lentils all right
then so let's see how they have done
Edward so this is actually a lentils not
black beans this is actually navy beans
not lima beans
couscous but you got right not millet
bulgur wheat
this is buckwheat cannellini beans these
are fava beans chickpeas these are split
peas and these are not Puy lentils but
green lentils you got four out of ten
these are not pinto beans so these are
actually navy beans
great for soups and stews black beans
tea so not no yeah see oh it's gonna ii
follow me so the reason you got these
wrong probably because you've probably
seen fava beans in their green form when
they're raw once they draw a mountain to
cook a bit turns black like this so you
got eight out of ten not bad
this is not millet but it's actually
bulgur wheat
very this was the chicken one very
similar yeah right
tabbouleh in Middle Eastern cuisine
that's where bulgur wheat is okay other
thing you got wrong is Beluga lentils
8 out of 10 not bad
so this I think you put it over here
these are cannellini beans and this is a
check light they look very similar
Canton and weenies are bigger buckwheat
millet this was the other one this is
the bulgur wheat that's it it's not a
disaster you got 6 out of 10
you got the lentils wrong and and you
know what it's a common mistake so these
are green lentils and these are actually
the boil lentils and the difference is
that these are actually from little town
in France called poit and they're sort
of known as the luxury version of
lentils they're really delicious really
nutty amazing so let's see you've got 6
out of 10
so that means Jessica I'm Brian you both
go through to the final with a school
but as amber and Jan both scored 6 out
of 10 they must play a tie-break
challenge we do have to say goodbye to
Chris who scored just 4 out of 10 all
right ladies for this tiebreak challenge
you must extract as much juice as
possible from the oranges provided in 30
seconds the person with the most juice
will go through to round 2 are you ready
time starts now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
is upon us Jan go ahead and pour the
contents of it right into your to be
very careful don't spit it only counts
at this in there let's check that out
you have 86 million years of OJ and
we're let's see if you did any better
[Music]
that you didn't quite make the juicing
cut but it's been great having you now
all that stands between our three
remaining contestants and $1,000 is the
final cook-off on your board you have a
really beautiful delicate fillet of cod
as well as the cod cheek I want you guys
to cook your heart out if you want to
use the grains that we played with
earlier today even better but create one
amazing dish for me contestants before
you can begin this final battle you'll
need ingredients from our pantry now you
only have two minutes and your time
starts
what is in our pantry today we've got
rights corn tortillas leeks fennel
avocado
there's bay leaves cardamom pods and I
know I saw so many things that it was
kind of like which direction am I gonna
go with this
thirty Seconds abital grab all you can
you might music you might not just grab
[Music]
you now have 25 minutes to create a cod
dish that is a worthy winner let the
battle begin
[Music]
[Applause]
what did you grab from the pantry
specifically show me a bit of everything
if you like Mexican inspired spices God
avocados tomatoes limes are you gonna
make me a taco yeah you've got a little
a little bit of spillage no this isn't
from our pantry no it's right of them
home yeah it's really garlicky I need to
dilute it yeah its chimichurri but it's
too garlic when I tasted it I was like
no this isn't how it normally tastes so
it's a bit worried but it's like I kind
of still want to use it cuz it's like
pow right tell me what specifically did
you grab for the pantry over here
bourbon oh you're talking my language
so how's the Bourdon one right bourbon
was the first thing I like bourbon so
tell me your dish then so pan-seared Cod
with hopefully a bourbon cream sauce
homemade pan fries and then you're using
bourbon in the dish yeah have you made a
bourbon cream sauce yeah okay just be
careful you gotta cook off the alcohol
okay oh yeah all right good luck well I
brought a little bit of everything I was
kind of going for all my favorite
flavors and I wanted
I am chopping up the cod cheek we're
lumping it into the line so I'm making
it at the ceviche here with the cod
cheek okay so tell me a little bit more
about what specifically you've grabbed
here from the pan fast launch roe and
lime and and shallots and chilli
cucumber and ginger and lemon is that's
a nice little pear we've got the Apple
fennel thing going on yeah it's gonna be
great you just named about 40
ingredients do you have a dish in your
head it's gonna be a trio
so ceviche ceviche yeah and then you're
gonna do great to get a poach okay and
then you're gonna get a grill all right
I don't see anything I don't see any
pans working on your own thing okay yeah
that's it shut you down
Go Go that's all I'm thinking Go Go Go
Go Go chef you know I always love to ask
you if it was your pantry what would you
have picked and made with that Cod man
cod is so beautiful I would do stew
using both the cod and the cheese kind
of like a San Francisco cioppino
you know a little tomato white wine bass
gently poach it throw some of the
lentils in there some fennel beautiful
Jessica's making South American fish
tacos using her chimichurri sauce that
she brought with her but she's not very
happy with it because of that garlic
content my god garlic that's not good
that's like garlic with a little bit of
green that's kind of chimichurri so you
know she has to be delicate with that
chimichurri branch and pan-seared cod in
a bourbon cream sauce bourbon singing
your two in there listen I hope he's not
using the Bourbon just to make me happy
because even though I like bourbon the
idea of bourbon cream sauce with fish
wouldn't be my first choice
amber is doing Cod three ways you said
it might be a little over-ambitious I
mean it seems like Amber's trying to
take my job from me with her ambition
it's it's a lot to do so she's got to
pick it up if she's really gonna do that
right this is a time competition you
guys just 15 minutes remaining 15
minutes
are using all their kitchen craft to
prepare a sumptuous Cod dish for Edward
Lee who will decide on a winner and I
want to see how they're doing cuz it
smells so good in here Brian I know
you're a teacher we're crazy at each
next high school and middle school so
what are you gonna do to impress your
students here today hopefully win try
try like try your hardest and as long as
you do sounds good in storybooks hello
there Jessica cooking up a storm here
are you the chimichurri sauce that we
were having some issues with before but
it was inspired by someone special and I
think someone's right here in the
audience right yeah my boyfriend's born
in Argentina and everyone in this family
raves about chimichurri but apparently I
butchered it today what do you think of
her chimichurri sauce don't normally
yeah they don't know what they're on
about its birthday just like Jessica
yeah we're on so it smells fantastic
good luck keep your house oh hello there
amber hi Tommy something don't wanna
mean to you to win the title culinary
genius
oh I'd probably just run all around
telling people really take it from me
I'm a culinary genius how you doing
Brian okay how's your taco
listen heigen one of these tortillas um
I've got some in the oven I don't want
those tortillas really crispy right they
got to be able to sort of be bending
what's going on here plates here I can't
I can't help you but this plates here
I can't help you I'm looking around I
can't find the plates where are the
plates ran finally found them I was
going to improvise meanwhile my god
you're full of nervous energy
okay all right guys please we got to
start plating we got to start plating
now
Brian he's shaking is he's trying to get
it on the plate I'm feeling calm but
inside I'm just a jumbled mess
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
genius where it is time for Edward to
judge what the cooks have created let's
go in I'm looking down at my plate and
and I'm really really proud of what I've
done today I don't think it's like the
best I could have done some kind of sad
but we'll see if he likes it
[Music]
presentation was kind of stressed by
chef several times so I'm not exactly
happy with way in which the plate top
goes obviously a very simple
presentation there's not much to say
about it
most of its gonna be in the flavors I'm
gonna go right in listen it's a taco
it's nice I like that you just use a
little bit of the chimichurri because
there's really strong yeah so I still
taste it but it's not overpowering when
you cook cod it'll naturally just flake
off so you didn't have to like keep
stirring it and grind out you cuz you
kind of ground it down I just wanted to
see a little bit more complexity I know
you got it in you but it's a good taco
okay I like that you cook the cod fillet
whole but what happened here because I
saw them in the pan they were roasting
nicely what happened when you presented
them shaky hands alright let's go ahead
and taste it it's nicely cooked [ __ ] you
get points for using lentils the
potatoes could have been crispier the
bourbon sauce is good could have used it
just a touch more bourbon but this is
really nice it just everything just
needed to be cooked a little bit longer
a little bit more finesse but the
concept I was surprised really works
really good job tell me what the menu
name of this dish would be Amber's zesty
zingy zany Cod wraps zesty Ziggy and
zany there are three I get it it's a
pretty dish but they all look like
chopped cod on greens all right let's go
in first
this guy was my favorite it had a nice
you know punch to it
the other two this was nice the avocado
with the pepper this one I felt was a
little bit bland I would have taken this
out and I would have just presented two
really beautiful presentations of chi
overall you really went for it
which I like and I really loved your
energy and I love you but you weren't
honored
would you learn one hundred percent
successful but I have applaud your
ambition all right Edward you've tasted
three Cod dishes they all cooked their
hearts out for you but now you have a
tough decision to make
why don't we take a walk
[Music]
to reveal today's winner finalists
please lift your cloches
[Music]
what you did that was so genius was you
kept that [ __ ] calejo you roasted it and
you put that barbeque rub on it so that
it was nice and moist and flaky when it
landed on that plate beautiful job
[Applause]